foreign
hi everyone I'm Bryce Buffalo and I'm a
product manager here at Google Cloud
focusing on assured workloads and I'm
David Williams Cloud manager for IMO and
insight where I lead the devops and
devsecops teams thanks for having me hey
Welcome to our session everyone where
we're going to make compliance fun
let's do this let's do it in this
session we will focus on four key areas
first the state of compliance where
we'll take an in-depth look at its
importance difficulties and trade-offs
in present day
second The Innovation that assured
workers have brought to this area and
the fact that this area has remained
largely unchanged for years
then I'll hand it over to David and
we'll walk through our Mountain's
journey to achieving their fedramp ATO
and the impact of compliance on their
business
and finally Google Cloud's plans for
enabling Global compliance
as we think about the state of
compliance we need to remember that as
Global Industries evolve and new threats
emerge that compliance has struggled to
keep Pace historically in the last two
years the pandemic recently caused risk
postures to change at an accelerated
rate to protect organizations which put
additional strain on compliance
Frameworks requiring revisions
exceptions and additional controls at a
historical pace
with all this change coming to a
traditionally slow innovating area we
need to take a moment and think about
why compliance has such a high
importance across Enterprises
at its core compliance represents the
requirements and best practices for
protecting the organization and its
sensitive information
this could be not this could not be more
critical in the current threat landscape
we see today
it provides a baseline for security
controls and Enterprise needs to gain
the trust of its customers
expanding across ethical Behavior
physical and Technical controls
processes and attestations all impacting
the reputation of the Enterprise
organization
in the last five years we have seen
Regulatory Compliance increase across
the globe in response to political
policy changes and Innovation including
cloud and high performance computing
customers across different Industries
leveraging these Technologies and
operating in these Geographic areas have
felt the pain of trying to adapt their
existing controls or adopt new controls
in response to threats or regulatory
changes
these changes add complexity when
working with Regulators putting
additional strain and risk on the
Enterprise organization
the options these Enterprises have been
left with are to keep these applications
and sensitive data on-premises and miss
out on the benefits of cloud in order to
reduce the risk to the organization or
move these workloads to a gov Cloud
where Innovation capacity and support is
limited in comparison to the commercial
Cloud offering
today Enterprises have to say have to
make trade-offs when supporting
regulated data they must compromise on
gov Cloud location and machine
availability along with accepting
technology two to three generations
behind creating toil and additional
costs for operations and development
teams some Enterprises turn to
self-hosted Solutions which are not
equal to Cloud
and lack access to AI machine learning
adaptability and robust security
controls these Solutions put heavy
burden on customers to operate hardware
and software that is not their own
but there is hope we saw this struggle
and we heard it from our Enterprise
customers that these trade-offs were not
what they wanted so we decided to create
a better way and assured workloads was
born
we focused the product on the concept of
shared fate
what this means is that Google Cloud
understands that our customers
businesses and Google clouds go hand in
hand we want to ensure customers that
regardless of where the responsibility
line is drawn they are not on their own
our mission is to shift more and more of
the customer responsibility left while
being there every step of the way to
help the customer understand and manage
the compliance privacy security and
reliability risk of their Cloud
investment
we exercise shared fate through assured
workloads by applying our mission
statement to everything we do
confidently secure and configure
sensitive workloads to support your
compliance requirements in the cloud
choose the security settings and we'll
put the necessary Cloud controls in
place a simple easy to use cloud-based
experience focused on reducing
compliance toil
the core controls to enable a compliance
are data residency for at rest in use
and in process
data access controls restricting support
access to adjudicated individuals
Key Management provided providing
cryptographic controls for customers on
or outside of the cloud access control
and access transparency giving customers
auditability of the cloud of the or and
control of access when Google admins are
fulfilling customer initiated support
requests and finally resource resource
restrictions preventing developers from
using non-compliant products and
services
customers are able to configure assured
workloads to support their compliance
requirements in just a few clicks
set your access requirements first
select the restricted location of your
data
finally you configure your keys and this
can be external Key Management customer
managed encryption keys or Google magic
keys
all of this is then put in place for you
in just a few clicks allowing you to
meet your Regulatory Compliance needs
I'm really excited to announce the
general availability of assured
workloads monitoring today and I want to
take a second and thank you David for
taking the time to bring tons of
customer input and feedback over the
last year to make today possible and I
want to thank you for being a true
partner and listening to the needs that
we have and then acting on them and
delivering
and we're going to keep delivering
thanks this is one of the many products
and features we will be introducing into
the assured workload Suite
this new monitoring service allows
Enterprise organizations to see their
compliance posture in real time giving
Enterprises an overall view of the
various guard rails in place and their
current state while allowing
adaptability of configurations to meet
the unique requirements the organization
has
assured workloads monitoring provides an
organizational view of assured workloads
folders detecting resource changes
against the Enterprise's desired
compliance state for each folder meaning
if there is a change that occurs and an
administrator is notified and provided
with an overview of the control at risk
details of the violation logs and
Remediation steps
this is a tremendous step in making
compliance easier on Google Cloud for
Enterprises
now I'll hand it over to David to
discuss how assured workloads helped
Iron Mountain reduce the complexities of
compliance and grow their business David
thanks first off what is insight
Iron Mountain Insight is a Content
Services platform that provides business
insights and Predictive Analytics
through machine learning
we use ml-based classification of a
company's physical and digital
information
once this data is ingested and indexed
it can then be searched for patents or
Trends as well as used to run
visualization and analytics tools
against business use cases
when we first began this journey we knew
right away that getting our fat ramp ATO
was going to be key to our future
successes
security is one of the core things that
Iron Mountain is known for
so we embarked on a roughly 12-month
process working through the iso sock and
this controls and with each step getting
us closer and closer to our ultimate
goal of fat wrap status
partnering with Google allowed us to
scale faster and tackle the complex
requirements needed to achieve fed ramp
status
through the shared responsibility and
shared fate model we are able to inherit
some compliance and security controls
and focus on others while Google takes
care of the heavy lifting
this allows us to confidently move the
business forward into the federal space
while simultaneously increasing the
overall security posture of our entire
platform in every vertical in the U.S
short workloads in a nutshell allowed us
to use our same code base across the
entire gcp platform the same ml apis the
same scalability but with the knowledge
that our customers who require a more
stringent set of controls are now
covered
data residency is a huge concern for us
and this allowed us to define the
environment variables restricting to a
specific region and knowing for certain
that the data is where it should be
no rooms for mistakes in the deployment
file or some manually create a resource
where everything is locked down with the
short workloads
another issue we have is with encryption
keys and who controls them
a short workload gives us default
encryption in transit and at rest as
well as a nice robust set of tools to
manage our own and our customers
encryption keys
all of these things combined plus access
to support engineers in the correct
Geographic locations give us and our
customers peace of mind as well as help
us achieve our ATO in record time
now Bryce how can we get these same
tools and functionalities in other
regions that we service
well the answer is as soon as possible
but in reality we are launching in
Europe already today and that's also
part of our plan is to launch in the
APAC and also Canada over the next year
so we're doing this in response to the
things that we've heard from you thank
you
so while working with Iron Mountain and
other customers to Support fedramp
Compliance we heard that exact question
what about the rest of the world in
response to this we launched assured
workloads into the EU as I mentioned
before and not only that we're also
launching our sovereignty requirements
which you'll hear a lot about during
other sessions during next
like also with our APAC in Canadian
region Canadian regions in preview today
we'll be pushing those forward over the
next year to get to a general
availability status to support the
compliance needs that you have
here's an example of how Enterprises are
able to support this Global compliance
use case in a single Google Cloud
organization
using the assured workloads API
Enterprises are able to create folders
with specific controls to support their
selected compliance type this creates a
regulated boundary in which resources
and data are labeled with the compliance
type restricting access locations and
enabling automated data classification
for customers
data data classification is crucial
because it allows customers to do
something they have not been able to do
in the passes understand where their
regulated data lives within the platform
or within their environment the
flexibility of this design enables
Enterprises to architect regulated
environments inside of existing Google
Cloud organizations and easily migrate
workloads as David had mentioned before
compliance can enable your organizations
to grow its business across the globe we
see a short workloads as a way for us to
get to a point where entering a
regulated market is a business decision
instead of a complex decision with
uncertainty and headaches along the way
we trust that Google's shared fate model
will continue to benefit Iron Mountain
by simplifying more and more of the
compliance responsibilities allowing us
to meet our customers needs globally
assured workloads is available for
customers to use today you can check it
out at cloud.google.com assured
workloads or the assured workloads
YouTube series for more detailed
information on how to get started
I just want to say thank you David for
taking the time today to come in and
talk to our customers about assured
workloads and also sharing your fedramp
journey for Iron Mountain I just want to
say thank you for everything that you've
done to help us along this journey and I
look forward to what comes next cool all
right thank you everyone bye everybody
foreign